S
INTERESTING AT SEVEN BARROWS
SOMEHOW KEEPING US IN THE LOOP
ON ALL THESE DETAILS. THANKS SO
MUCH. CNN SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST
JOINS ME NOW AND ELLIE LOOKED AT
THE JUDGE DID OFFER THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENTS AND PROTECTIONS
ABOUT WHAT HE HAS TO SHARE ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH
WHEN HE WAS OPERATING AS EVER
NOTED AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE, BUT HE DID HAVE TO
TESTIFY ABOUT HIS CONVERSATIONS
WITH FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IN,
BUT DOES HE HAVE TO TESTIFY
ABOUT THIS CONVERSATIONS LEADING
UP TO THE ATTACK? WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS ACTUAL DECISION
HERE? WELL PHIL ON BALANCE. THIS
IS A REAL WIN FOR PROSECUTORS
FOR THE SPECIAL COUNSEL BECAUSE
NOW THEY WILL GET TO QUESTION
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT MIKE
PENCE UNDER OATH ABOUT VIRTUALLY
EVERYTHING THAT THEY'LL NEED TO
ASK HIM ABOUT. NOW THEY CANNOT
ASK HIM ABOUT WHAT HE DID ON
JANUARY 6TH ITSELF BECAUSE HE
WAS ACTING AS VICE PRESIDENT AS
SENATE PRESIDENT. SO THAT'S
WALLED OFF UNDER AS EVAN
DESCRIBED THE SPEECH AND DEBATE
CLAUSE, BUT THEY'RE GOING TO GET
TO QUESTION HIM UNDER OATH ABOUT
EVERYTHING LEADING UP TO JANUARY
6TH, INCLUDING KEY MEETINGS THAT
HE HAD ONE ON ONE WITH DONALD
TRUMP IN THE DAYS LEADING UP TO
JUNIOR 36 WHERE THEY DISCUSSED
THIS PLOT WHERE I WOULD WANT TO
ASK MIKE PENCE. WHAT DID DONALD
TRUMP TELL YOU? WHAT DID HE ASK
YOU TO DO? THOSE ARE CRUCIAL
CONVERSATIONS NOW PENCE AND
TRUMP CAN APPEAL THIS TO THE
COURT OF APPEALS. I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE LIKELY TO GET A
DIFFERENT OUTCOME. I THINK THIS
IS LIKELY TO STICK AS THE RESULT
AND IT'S A WIN FOR PROSECUTORS
LAID OUT AND YOU NOTED ON SOME
OF THEM THAT THERE'S A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS. WE STILL NEED ANSWERS
TO IN TERMS OF TIMING WITH THE
ACTUAL PROCESS WOULD BE GOING
FORWARD. ONE QUESTION I HAD IS
KEN, THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
STILL PLEAD THE FIFTH TO AVOID
ANSWERING QUESTIONS THAT AREN'T
WALLED OFF HERE SO LEGALLY AND
CONSTITUTIONALLY? ABSOLUTELY YES
, MIKE. PENCE LIKE ANY PERSON
CAN CLAIM THE FIFTH AND THAT
WOULD PREVENT HIM FROM HAVING TO
TESTIFY. HOWEVER FIRST OF ALL,
HE WOULD NEED SOME BASIS ON
WHICH TO ARGUE THAT HIS
TESTIMONY MIGHT INCRIMINATE HIM.
AND SECOND OF ALL, I'M NOT SURE
HE'S WILLING TO TAKE ON THE
POLITICAL DAMAGE THAT WOULD COME
WITH TAKING THE FIFTH. ALSO FILL
IF MIKE PENCE OR ANY WITNESS
TAKES THE FIFTH, THEN
PROSECUTORS CAN ACTUALLY USE A
COUNTERMOVE. TO OVERCOME THAT
THEY CAN IMMUNIZE HIM.
ESSENTIALLY THEY WOULD SAY OKAY
, MIKE PENCE OR ANYONE ELSE. YOU
TAKE THE FIFTH. WE'RE GOING TO
AGREE THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
USE YOUR TESTIMONY AGAINST YOU.
AND NOW YOU HAVE TO TESTIFY. AND
THAT IS NOT OPTIONAL. THAT IS
NOT VOLUNTARY, SO WE COULD SEE A
LITTLE BACK AND FORTH HERE
TOTALLY DO WANT TO TURN TO THE
MANHATTAN GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATION INTO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ALLEGED ROLE IN
$130,000 PAYMENT TO STORMY
DANIELS BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION
. YESTERDAY, THE GRAND JURY
HEARD TESTIMONY FROM DAVID
PECKER, THE FORMER HEAD OF THE
COMPANY THAT PUBLISHES THE
NATIONAL ENQUIRER. AND HAS
ALREADY TESTIFIED BEFORE THE
GRAND JURY. WHY DO YOU THINK
PROSECUTORS WANTED TO BRING HIM
BACK? SO THE KEY TO
UNDERSTANDING THIS IS
UNDERSTANDING? AS YOU JUST SAID,
THIS IS DAVID PECKERS. SECOND
TIME IN THE GRAND JURY. HE WAS
PART OF THE PROSECUTION'S
ORIGINAL PRESENTATION. AND THEN
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER THAT? IS THE
DEFENSE DONALD TRUMP'S TEAM HAD
THIS LAWYER BOB COSTELLO GO IN,
AND HE TOLD US AFTERWARDS THAT
WHAT HE DID WAS BASICALLY
ATTACKED MICHAEL COHEN'S
CREDIBILITY. AND SO I THINK IT
STANDS TO REASON DAVID PECKER
WAS CALLED TO REBUT THAT AND TO
TRY TO REHABILITATE MICHAEL
COHEN'S CREDIBILITY, EITHER
SPECIFICALLY AS TWO POINTS AN